so I have made a decision in the past
few minutes I think that they are not
teaching critical thinking school
critical thinking skills in journalism
school anymore and I also think that
journalism students should not be
allowed to write stories on economics
because it makes them look like fools
Wall Street Journal has a five page
article today that starts off this way
families go deeply into debt to stay in
the middle class in order to maintain
the middle class the American
middle-class is falling deeper into debt
to maintain a middle-class lifestyle
cars college houses medical care becomes
steadily more costly but incomes have
been largely stagnant for two decades
now then they go on for the next five
pages of this article explained how car
debt is at a record credit card debt is
at a record student loan debt is at a
record all things we knew and that
middle-class wages are stagnant and so
the wealth gap of the wealthy are
getting wealthier the poor middle class
is being eaten alive and you all are all
a victim of evil capitalism and the
Socialists are going to come and rescue
you with a plan that has never worked in
any country in the history of the world
and that's the premise of this bullcrap
and I can't believe this is in the
freaking Wall Street Journal okay
yes middle-class wages by and large are
stagnant but let me tell you what's
happened to the middle class while I've
been alive I grew up in middle-class
suburban Nashville middle class in 1960
I grew up in a house that was a thousand
square feet and we finished out part of
the basement made it 1,300 feet which is
actually the median square footage of a
house in 1960 in the United States you
know what the median square footage of
the middle-class house right now is in
the United States 2600 middle class
ain't what it used to be the house has
doubled our cars we had one car we had
two-forty air conditioning you rolled
down boat to windows and drove 40 miles
an hour we didn't have DVD players and
only rich people had cars with electric
windows we cranked ours down by our own
little but used our little muscles to do
that
they weren't that reliable they weren't
that great they wouldn't park themselves
and none of the doors opened
automatically and there were no holes in
the roof except ones we didn't want if
you had a convertible or an electric
window in 1960 on your car you were a
rich person not a middle-class person
now if you don't have a moonroof an
automatic door a GPS and an auto parking
and the freaking thing drives for you
because god forbid your two children
should have to sit together in a seat
and you call that middle-class oh if you
went to college in the 1960s you went to
an in-state school or community school
you lived at home and you worked your
little butt off to pay for it and if you
graduated in four years and got a
four-year degree you were a big deal
nowadays you have to go to a school
that's prestigious and you have to stay
18 years and get a graduate degree to
call yourself middle-class and pay 16
times more for it to call yourself
middle-class when we went on vacation
when I was a kid we got in a 13-foot
boat with a 35 horse Johnson on it drove
over to the island with a lawn mower
mowed out of place and went tent camping
and waterskiing consisted of a lot of
dragging in a little bit of skiing now
if you want to go out on the lake it
takes a hundred and ten thousand dollar
wakeboard boat because you have to surf
behind the boat and there ain't no
camping involved unless it's in an RV
that cost a hundred grand in the
middle-class America of today the
Sharron and I got married in 1982 we put
our little butts in the car we drove
from Tennessee to Key Largo and stayed
in the Holiday Inn and we thought we
were big time because all of our friends
when they got married went to Gatlinburg
we went to Florida when I was a kid
growing up I never saw the ocean until I
was 14 years old I must have been abused
as a child I don't know how we
middle-class people made it the things
that you people all call middle-class
today we called rich when we were in the
middle class of the 1960's and 1970's if
you wanted to cut make a phone call you
put your finger in a thing and turn it
around a rotary phone and it was
connected to the wall and you never
called long distance because it costs
more now if you can't FaceTime someone
in China you're pissed off in your hand
and you call that middle class if you
want to turn on the television it was
free and you spun the rabbit ears around
and the channel changer was my dad
telling me to get up and change the
channel
and there were three channels it won the
$200 a month with the NFL package the
Golf Channel package the SEC package oh
when you got to have Netflix for another
10 or 20 bucks oh and you got to have
Apple TV this is middle class you know
when we went to a restaurant on special
occasions you freaking middle-class
people today eat out every night and if
you can't you whine like a 13 year old
girl at the lunch table in middle school
and you call that middle class your
wages might be stagnant but let me tell
you what's not stagnant your freakin
consumption you are consuming your butts
off America and don't blame it on
capitalism blame it on your immaturity
and your impulsiveness and don't you
dare say that the wealthy are getting
wealthier on your backs you're living
like you're rich and you're not it's
your fault
oh you're shaming yes I
shaming that's what you call that it's
calling stupid stupid this is critical
thinking skills it's not a stagnant
income that's a problem it's an
exponential increase in consumption
instead of production get up leave the
cave and make more than you spend and
try not calling all of these luxury
items that were reserved for the richest
of the rich only two decades ago please
don't call those middle-class and that
you are somehow entitled to them because
you woke up and breathed American air
this morning absolutely asinine you
cannot eat out every night have cable TV
packages have a phone that does what
your phone does fly the Dominican
Republic on your honeymoon and have an
all-inclusive adventure at the beach
you cannot vacation instead of a tent in
Europe and all over cruising all over
the world you cannot have a private
school with a graduate degree two cars
that will dance a jig and live in a
house twice the size as I grew up in and
call yourself middle-class and somehow
you've been messed over by America what
a bunch of crap